[Musique]
et on commence ces informations Gabriel
par une rencontre un élu saintcantinois
été reçu hier soir place beauovau au
ministère de l'Intérieur et des autres
maires oui tout à fait Mathilde le maire
de laavrière Nicolas d'unville était
convié par le ministre Gérald de
Darmanin 60 parlementaires et 150 maires
avaient également répondu présent à
l'invitation objectif évoquer le sujet
du pouvoir des mares contre l'insécurité
et les incivilités sur XX Twitter l'élu
yvelinois demande une extension des
pouvoirs de la police municipale suite à
un sentiment d'impuissance des communes
on prend la direction de morpa à présent
où un nouveau système d'imagerie
médicale a été installé oui un un
appareil DIRM a été inauguré hier soir
au centre médical des pyramides cette
technique de rendu multidimensionnel par
champ magnétique et notamment utilisé en
cancérologie ou encore en gynécologie
attendu depuis plus de 10 ans le centre
a obtenu l'autoris d'installation auprès
de l'agence régionale de santé il y a un
an cet été la machine est entrée en
fonctionnement avec moins de 40 IRM sur
tout le département cette arrivée
répondait à une demande de la population
lesction les réactions au micro de
Julien Leroi il faut effectivement
montrer pas de Blanche montrer qu'on est
capable
d'instruire un tel dossier qu'on est
capable d'installer une machine mais
aussi il faut montrer qu'on apporte un
vrai plus aux patients il faut montrer
qu'on s'intègre dans tout le réseau de
soins il y avait un vrai projet de santé
en particulier basé sur l'imagerie de la
femme puisquon a un spécialiste le
docteur FIDA qui fait beaucoup
d'imagerie de la femme et qui est réputé
et donc on a des patientes sur toute
l'île de France qui viennent ici pour
passer le leurs IRM pelvienne je crois
que c'était attendu par nos par nos
habitants et aussi par les cquantinois
de manière générale contenu aussi vous
le savez de la pénurie de médecin sur le
territoire donc on sait que maintenant
voilà on a une IRM qui vient en plus du
scanner qui était arrivé il y a il y a
quelques quelques années un élément
d'attractivité supplémentaire pour le
territoire de morpa pour son bassin de
vie on poursuit ses informations Gabriel
avec un tableau volé de Joséphine de
beauoharnet il a été restitué hier à son
propriétaire oui ce portrait peint en
1804 de l'impératrice avait été dérobé
en février 2022 lors de ses vacances le
couple propriétaire de l'œuvre se fait
cambrioler dans sa maison des ivelines
ce tableau est retrouvé dans une salle
des ventes aux enchères à Paris en
novembre 2022 le prix de vente surestimé
fait le commissaire priser et les
explications du vendeur ne sont pas
claires après une enquête quatre
personnes sont interpellées ce mercredi
le portrait a été remis à son
propriétaire par le groupement de
gendarmerie des Yvelines à Versailles un
soulagement pour lui dont sa famille est
détentrice de l'œuvre Mathilde depuis
son origine on parle maintenant
d'entrepreneuriat cet après-midi avait
lieu une rencontre entre entrepreneur à
l'incubateur ski cube de saintquenttins
en Yveline oui les rencontres 2023
c'était le nom de cet événement adressé
au porteur de projets il était organisé
pour la 9e année consécutive par
l'association créative cybersécurité
intelligence artificielle ou qualité de
vie au travail expert et chefs
d'entreprise animer des conférences pour
partager leur parcours objectif
accompagner une cinquantaine
d'entrepreneurs dans leur démarche de
création d'entreprise on écoute les
réactions au micro de Clara de Frutos
une conférence porte autour de des
innovations technologiques avec les
cyber justement les cyber attaques et
l'intelligence artificielle euh une
autre conférence porte sur les la RSE et
la QVT dans les entreprises et une autre
conférence qui porte sur la reconversion
professionnelle avec d'anciens sportifs
de haut niveau reconvertis dans
l'entrepreneuriat une initiative
solidaire maintenant ce samedi aura lieu
la 3e édition de l'éclair day oui un
petit plaisir pour lutter contre la
maladie boulanger pâtissiers et clients
sont invités à participer à une journée
solidaire ce 18 novembre le principe
Mathilde le client achète sa pâtisserie
en payant un petit supplément tandis que
le vendeur offre les ingrédients
l'ensemble du prix de l'éclair est
reversé à l'association imagine for
Margot des fonds utilisés pour lutter
contre le cancer de l'enfant cette
maladie elle touche aujourd'hui chaque
année 2500 enfants en France l'année
dernière 15000 éclairs avaient été
vendus et 40000 € avaient été collectés
l'ensemble des points de vente
participants est à retrouver sur le site
imagine for
Margot pardon qui s'affiche en bas de
votre c'est une bonne initiative ça
merci beaucoup Gabrielle Gontier pour
toutes ces informations et comme
d'habitude si vous aussi vous voyez une
image ou une information qui vous a
marqué près de chez vous n'hésitez pas à
nous la partager sur les réseaux sociaux
en utilisant le hashtag 7et news